I forgot to turn the music on.
What do you
mean, why does G hate us anymore?
I start... I start... not exactly on time.
I think everybody's clocks are now slow.
Compared to my clock, which is... fast.
Where's the Minto on the thumbnail?
Oh, dead?
You're haunting our clocks.
Potentially.
Potentially, potentially.
Anyway, welcome to Age of Empires.
Do you know of Red Alert 3?
I feel like I've heard of it before.
Red Alert 3.
Plots are very silly as pretty military girls.
Feels like it'd be really up your alley for an RTS game.
I've seen some people in chat being like, Oh my gosh, RTS Minto, RTS Ark.
And I just want to say, whoa, that's...
Hold your horses a little bit.
A little bit.
You know, I enjoy these types of games, but I'm not quite so sweaty about them, so I fear that it might turn people off of wanting to Wanting to watch me Play them, you know, so But for now, I really wanted to play Age of Empires 2 because Because, because When I was a wee wisp I would sit in Papa Minto's lap and I would watch Sometimes control the mouse,
you know, like when Well, actually I went to, when I went to school I had a bus driver that would let the kids drive the bus But I think she got fired.
I was gonna say
It's like when the bus driver lets you drive the bus But I don't think that's That's the
Yeah, she would, she would, she would, you know She would press the pedals And then the kids would steer, right?
And And I think someone, I think someone snitched But they thought it was probably like Hey mom, my bus driver, today the bus driver let me drive the bus And the mom is probably just like What?
Yeah Anyway, well I was gonna say it's like that Oh, I know what I was thinking of It's like when you, when you were a kid and you would sit In the, oh my gosh, you know those You know those wheels that they put in carts Like a shopping cart And you pretend you're driving the shopping cart It's like that,
that's what it was It's me watching my, my papa play I would, I would, I would not actually be doing anything I was just But sometimes I do remember I would go into like the custom mode And I would do like one man versus like 15 Joan of Arcs and 25 elephants And every Every warrior and I'd put them on opposite sides of the map And I would see how long it took to To,
to reach each other You did that too?
There's no such thing as an original An original experience, is there?
Scenario editor was fun Yeah, I used to enjoy just kind of being goofy in there Taser is god tier song on the soundtrack No one beats the rumbling from my elite war elephants I believe you Everybody is saying references to things Being like, oh, Minto played Age of Empires Yeah,
when I was a babby But that's okay Maybe we'll understand later Age of Mint-par Shrinky But yeah, babu When I was just a little baby So, I can learn So you guys say all these references, I don't know right now But I will learn them
And, when was that?
Last week?
Yeah, last week I wish
I, earlier, actually, I did the tutorial Most of it I did most of the tutorial, I didn't do this one But just to kind of get an idea of things I was prepared Because these also take a long time So I feel that maybe we can just jump into a campaign or something I don't know Maybe we can do the last one together Oh wait,
go away, go away This one, the battle Maybe The series has amazing cheat codes You know, I...
Feel like I used cheat codes But But, maybe I'm confusing it with the Sims
I don't remember I might be confusing it with the Sims
AoE3 lets you summon giant George Washington bus that stomps on things What the heck, that's amazing Maybe let's play the game for real and then at the end we can do some silly cheat code stuff How about that?
I mean, it was my birthday over the weekend, may I ask for a song?
I'm traveling right now, put a few pics of traveling Minto on Blue Sky I have to check Blue Sky, I think I don't remember my Blue Sky login I was playing a bit of AoE as a kid, Wololo, but...
And I'm keen to see it again How do I say your name?
I hope I'm saying it right
Happy birthday!
I do have a password manager, I'm just Emma I'm just not good about using it sometimes Also, ConfusedDude, welcome to membership!
And therapy, thank you for the superchat!
Minto's Empire of Ocelots You spelled snakes wrong Sankies Sankies I wonder why...
So, maybe I'm just biased I chose Age of Empires 2 because that's the one I played as a kid But...
Is it like... I feel like it's the most popular one, right?
It's still popular It's also... It holds up so well as a game, I feel Did you ever play Age of Mythology?
Not as much as this one When I was a kid, it was Age of Empires, Diablo 2, Neverwinter Nights With my dad Those are like my three... Tomb Raider, a little bit I can't remember Oh my god!
I talked about this one before!
I talked about this one before Yeah, my dad was a gamer But...
Yeah, Blade Runner is one that I talked about But I... There was a... What's it called?
Hold on A pirate's game that I used to play with my dad And...
Is he single?
No, he's dead
But he...
He...
He would play this pirate's game and I brought it up to my mom and my sister last time I saw them And I was like...
What was that pirate's game that we used to play?
I can't... I could not remember it and I could not look it up or anything And my sister, she was just like... Oh yeah, we used to play that How did you guys know?
How did you guys know it was Sid Meier's Pirates?
How did you guys know?
Why didn't you guys ever say this before?
Maybe you guys did say it last time I brought it up
I don't know It's the pirate game But yeah, she was just like, it was this one.
I was like...
And I looked it up and I was like, it is that one!
I never asked Yes I did!
I have brought it up on stream before I have.
It's pronounced like shiver.
I'm sorry!
Happy birthday shiver I think we have another birthday too.
Hold on!
Oh no!
Oh sorry.
I see Minto with an army of cinnamoroll Wait.
Mr. Fried!
Happy birthday!
Hold on.
Sorry I clicked out of the game and then...
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday Mr. Fried!
But yeah, now I'm just like... I have to find a way... I don't think it was on Steam.
Let me see.
Hold on.
Cid?
I don't think so.
I think only Civilization is...
Oh shit sorry.
I'm on the Plague Inc.
Cid my... No only Civ... Civ... 5 Or is it?
It's on GOG.
It's on Steam now!
Pirates!
Oh my god.
That's the game!
I have to play this one too.
Oh my god.
Why does it look so... It looks so crisp.
Like the graphics look so sharp.
I like how there is a pirate bundle.
Anyway.
I didn't realize it was on Steam.
Let's go.
Okay.
Let's do the tutorial.
Number 7.
The Battle of Falkirk.
Falkirk.
Will you check out the new Toho RTS?
The Toho Empires?
When it come... What?
What?
What is that?
The Toho Empires?
Goblin takes your six months!
Toho Empires.
Dang it.
Sorry I cannot spell.
Or rather I have no autocorrect on my phone.
Oh my god!
I want to play it.
It was my birthday yesterday.
Oh my goodness.
Too many birthdays.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Rumor.
Happy birthday!
And Pinkerton, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Thank you.
What was I going to say?
Oh yeah, someone said it's not an official game.
That's like most Toho games I feel.
I feel like 90% of them are...
Maybe not even 90.
99% of them are doujin.
Okay, Scotland forever.
Let's go!
The only...oh.
I saw my message.
I don't think I did Yoshi.
Oh, that's it?
Ok.
We must build a castle!
Wow!
Oh wow!
I do.
Ok, we need more stone.
Do we have gold here?
The English can attack at any time!
Oh my gosh, another birthday!
Oh gosh, I can't click on chat anymore or else it sends me into the Dark Ages.
Into the Shadow Realm.
But I can see because people are responding.
Dr. Kocho, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday Dr. Kocho!
No!
We are getting attacked!
Oh my god, where are my people?
Where?
Down here!
Oh my god.
Wait!
Oh my gosh, I accidentally clicked left click.
I'm panicking.
Send my men!
No!
Oh my god.
We need...Oh my gosh.
We need more...more...more battle info...
Oh no!
Let's create like...
Five...
The English are here!
The English are coming!
Oh my god.
Can you like attack that thing?
You too!
Oh my god!
Go out!
They are attacking my stuff!
I'm getting attacked by the English!
Ok, can you like do anything?
Come on now.
It's time to...oh wait.
Hold on.
You do that one.
Ok.
The castle age.
Are they dead?
No, we are.
Wait.
No!
My people are dead!
They are just chilling there though, so let's leave.
We'll leave.
We'll let them do whatever.
Ok, hold on.
Wait, there are more guys over here.
Oh my god.
What are you doing?
They are so aggressive!
This is nothing like the previous tutorials.
I was chilling!
What do you think he's doing?
What do you think he's doing down there?
Oh, he's gone.
He's coming to kill my people.
Hold on, let's send some people over this way.
He's hunting us!
Ok, he's like...he literally was just gonna come and sneak.
Oh my god!
What is he doing?
Hello?
He has no survival instincts whatsoever.
What about these guys down here?
Are they still here?
Yes, they are!
The monk is the one that goes...
Kill that guy!
Oh, they are still coming.
Go away!
I love their little skeletons.
Yeah, get his ass!
It might be a...it might be a...
It might be a trap.
Actually, stop, stop, stop.
No!
Oh my god, it was a trap!
Oh my god, I knew it.
This guy sucks.
Oh wait!
Attack him, attack him, attack him.
Attack him.
Oh, he's dead.
It was a trap!
Ok.
We have more...more army being created.
Before, literally you guys, I was...
Wait, I should do what?
I should...
I have enough resources.
Oh, let's go to the Castle Age.
Where is my town center?
Oh, here.
Castle Age, baby!
I need more people.
This is ridiculous.
I was so chill the other...
Literally, the other...
Oh wait, I have two idle people.
Oh, chop down some wood.
Thank you.
I was chilling in the other tutorials.
And now suddenly...
Of course, as soon as I get on stream...
Oh, I don't have enough food.
We need more people.
We need more...
We need meat.
We need gatherers.
We need dudes.
I'm gonna send this guy...
Here, go up...
What's our land looking like over here?
It's kind of the edge of the map, but I still want to see.
Maybe we can find some sheep.
We want some meat.
Send more dudes.
Let's just...
Oh, look at his trampling through our farms.
Oh.
It is...
We're landlocked.
What about in here?
We haven't even discovered our whole village.
That's it.
I'm
gonna make more people.
Since we're getting more food.
Okay, let's go!
And then they said something about like...
Okay, build a castle and then destroy the English castle.
Oh yeah.
Didn't I create a guy?
Oh, it's creating now.
Okay.
Alright, lady.
Yeah, you're gonna build...
You're gonna build that.
The siege workshop.
You're gonna build it...
Guys, you're gonna learn I'm not good at placement.
Who's attacking me where?
Stop!
God, these guys are so freaking annoying.
Goodbye little outpost.
This guy is not doing anything.
Go kill that one guy.
Oh my god, they're leaving.
Are they leaving?
Maybe they're coming this way.
They might be wanting to attack us.
Oh my god.
Oh, okay.
That works, actually.
No, my scout!
He's dead.
Okay.
Battering rams.
Alright.
Good job.
We're getting gold.
Do we have a...this is our marketplace, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Tread cart.
What is this?
Oh, just a house.
It's so cute.
These places are so cute, right?
They're getting us wood.
The narrator is proud of me.
Oh, hey, hey!
Don't just stand around, buddy.
Let's get some more people.
For stone and for...
other stuff.
We're gonna also...
Oh, there's like baddies just...
Oh my god!
I think all my people are dead.
Oh no, they're not!
Lazy bones?
What are you doing over there?
Watching AoE2 competitive vids in 2020 is such a weird feeling.
Shh.
Oh, our outpost.
They're just destroying the wood by wood.
This sucks.
Yeah, take them down!
Hold on.
This one.
We're gonna upgrade, upgrade.
Love the thumbnail, it's so cute.
Thanks!
Oh my god!
Do anything!
They're gonna destroy all our outposts.
Kill them all!
Kill this guy!
Kill him!
Kill him.
Yeah, kill him too.
Yeah!
It's on fire.
Go back home.
It'll make it, probably.
It'll be fine, maybe.
We can get the long swordsman.
It sucks that there's like no sheep or anything around here.
Let's do...
Militia line costs, and the mine is 15 food.
And this one, they do more damage to buildings.
Oh, I have people that are bored.
Alright, I put you to slavery.
Actually, it's not really.
It's actually real honest work.
Pikemen are goaded?
Are they?
Okay, we'll make a lot of them.
Create more pike... Oh, I have not enough wood.
I need more wood.
Many of you will die, but that is a sacrifice I'm willing to make.
No!
We need more wood.
Luckily, the tutorial allows us to have a bajillion people.
We have a real empire.
Look at all these guys chilling here.
This is the army.
I'm like, should I make more outposts?
Oh no!
He scouted my area!
Don't do it.
People.
Okay.
Hello.
Go...
And you too.
Actually...
Yeah, we have...
We need more wood.
Can you pause the game?
Oh my god.
Run, run, run!
Oh, it's someone's birthday.
JSoul!
I'm sorry, I didn't see it.
Happy birthday to you.
F10 is to pause.
Happy birthday, JSoul!
Happy birthday!
Look, this is the most sturdy outpost ever.
It's amazing.
How it just stands.
I'm going to put...
I was going to say I'm going to put all my guys on that side, but I think we also need to finish our walls.
Okay, hold on.
Let's get a...
Let's get a... Let's make... Let's create life.
Let's create life and they will be our... Let's create two lives.
And also more pikemen.
Not enough wood.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, this too.
Okay, we created life.
Where?
These... Oh my gosh.
He saw that they were...
Alright everybody.
Go!
Attack this guy actually.
Oh no!
Why do they hate my outpost so much?
What do you mean I don't have enough wood for what?
Oh God!
It's falling!
Why didn't they see the...
I killed those guys.
You're outnumbered!
Kill him!
Oh God!
More are coming.
Oh gosh.
They must be like right here.
The waters will turn red tonight.
With your blood!
Alright, let's go home.
Good job team.
They're coming.
We have people.
They're being created.
Slowly but surely.
We'll create more all purpose men too.
Build a gate?
Yeah, I'm working on it.
I'm trying to.
Every two seconds I get...
Wait, it's a...
No, not repair.
I mean I could.
It's kind of cooler though if it's not, you know.
Here it is.
A gate.
Wait, how do I... Oh, here it is.
Build gate.
Can be built into wall.
Oh, this one looks better.
Wait, so we build the wall... Wait, so do I build the wall first?
And then do I build the gate into the wall?
Yeah?
So like this.
Go build!
You too lady.
Everybody... You're going to build the other side.
OK ma'am?
Now put the gate.
Oh!
I see!
We have no more outposts.
We have to build our castle soon.
Let's see.
I need a little cavalry.
I'm going to create...
I'm going to create a scout cavalry.
He's going to go searching for a bit.
Nice!
Look at them go!
Yeah baby!
Mind that stone.
Oh, we're almost out of stone.
The outposts were only holding us back my lord.
Build the castle in the swamp.
I want to build a little fishing area, honestly.
But they keep coming around here.
You know?
They keep coming to this side.
But I want to build a little dock and have some fish food coming in.
What if... Oh my gosh.
What if I'm a genius and I build the wall this way?
And then we get all of this.
We could do that.
Do it.
I will.
Oh my gosh, we have bored people.
Alright everybody.
Everybody who is bored, build a stone wall.
Actually, build a watchtower.
Do the watchtowers go inside or outside?
I mean, I know you can put them anywhere technically.
But what's the best...
Who is she playing as?
We are doing the tutorial.
Inside is better?
Okay.
Yeah, go build that, buddy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get inside.
It's not safe out there.
Eeyore, thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
Okay, and then the wall.
Oh my birthday!
P.K.A.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday.
Wait, hold on.
The castle.
Oh we have plenty.
Okay.
Happy birthday to you.
Oh my gosh!
You guys, go get this guy.
Go get this guy.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday P.K.A.
Happy birthday!
Kick this guy's ass.
Where did he go?
Oh my god, he's a ghost.
Where the hell did he go?
Where did he go?
Yeah, I don't want him scouting.
Okay, we gotta build the wall.
We gotta build it now.
Alright, come here, come here.
Over here, over here, over here.
Alright, start building.
We're gonna build... It's a little unconventional.
Like that.
Or like...
This uses less stone.
Okay.
Alright, everybody else is bored?
Yep, you too.
Go build it.
Go build that.
Okay.
Oh my god!
He's in my walls!
Guys, there's like ten of you.
Come on!
What?
You guys too!
Go kill him!
Yes, good.
He's in my walls.
Okay, we're gonna have like the most secure...
We're gonna have the most secure place ever now.
Nobody worry.
Wait...
Oh my gosh, they're so fast.
Let's go.
And now I can... After they build the wall, we'll build the statue... Not statue, sorry.
We'll build the...
We'll build our castle right over here.
Wherever we feel like, honestly.
They won't be able to walk there.
I will shoot them if they walk in the water, okay?
Just don't...
We got some gold over here.
Oh my god!
Everybody!
Everybody attack!
It's okay, they're outnumbered in our society.
Let's build some more archers.
We'll do... These guys are probably fast, right?
Cavalry archers, regular archers, scrimmage archers...
We'll get some knights.
Oh, the round table.
Cavalry will move faster.
Oh, the research.
Look there.
Oh, hey guy.
Get back to work.
If only we could have seen them coming.
We do, we do.
Look, they'll never be able to get in now.
Next is, once they're done with the wall, we build their castle.
We're gonna build it right... right there.
I wish I could chop down all these trees and build it in the middle.
I guess I technically could.
Boss, can we have some nanomachines?
This is the stone ages, I'm sorry.
You're gonna get rocks in your...
We have a scout?
It's ok, he can't get in.
He can't get in.
See?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
You, you, you, you, you, you.
Hold on, hold on.
Build it like super fast.
Build it as fast as you can.
Build it, build it, build it, build it.
Build it, build it, build it.
Make 20 more villagers and that forest will disappear forever.
True.
This too.
We need to build scorpions, battering rams.
Ok, they built it a little too slowly, but we'll get them next time, boys.
Oh yeah, the dock.
Ok, I do want to build a dock.
Here, let's get her to build one.
Also, I want fishies.
There we go.
And you, all by your lonesome.
What am I running out of?
What do I not have?
Oh, wood.
Good thing a castle is only stone.
Oh, that's like the smallest thing ever.
It would have looked so good there, right?
Put it near the walls.
No!
Nice, we got a boat.
I'm gonna...
Put it close to the gate.
Wait, why?
Like here?
I wish I could turn it.
Can I?
It shoots arrows.
Ok.
Welcome to my abode.
It's a direct entrance to my home.
Alright.
Transport ship.
Trade.
Galley.
Warship!
This game taught me copy-paste functions with cheats.
I believe that.
Alright, ma'am.
You also go.
Ok, so far they've been quiet.
Too quiet.
Name it Minto's Evil Castle of Doom.
I will.
I'll name it that.
And another one?
Oh gosh, we need more wood for real.
Alright, I'm gonna make some people stop working on certain things.
Let's see.
How do I have zero people working on stone?
Where'd they go?
Uh...
I think they gave up.
We're gonna have you working on lumber now.
I think I accidentally selected them when we were fighting.
So, alright.
We need more food!
And we need more wood.
What?
There is wood.
That too!
They should thank him!
Sir William.
Wow.
Research Stronghold.
Makes your castle and tower stronger by making them fire 33% faster.
And it heals!
Who's Wallace?
Where is he?
Wallace has come.
Where?
Oh my god!
Wallace.
Hello.
Hello my...wow.
Wallace brought it home!
One of your most powerful units is created at the castle.
Create ten more wood raiders.
Wood raider.
Ok.
And a petard.
What is that?
Demolition!
Did Wallace bring grommet?
Staff, thank you so much for the gifted!
Celtic Unique Infantry Unit.
Oh good, it's just gold and I have enough of that.
Ten of them.
Alright, get inside!
Get inside everybody!
Even the boats.
This guy is really trying.
No, no, no.
Come over here.
Wow.
Can ghosts be a little rude?
With William Wallace and his wood raiders on your side, the English may be in trouble.
Once you have a large army with plenty of siege weapons, go destroy the English castle.
Ok!
Oh my gosh.
Exciting.
Sorry, my cough is a little... It's been getting kind of not great recently.
I'm not quite sure why.
Ok, we'll do like what?
Two battering rams.
This thing.
We need more wood.
Not enough wood.
That's the plague.
Maybe.
Wait, I don't have enough wood to make a new farm?
Uh oh, we are in big trouble.
Let's also... I think we need some more gold.
You can upgrade your stuff.
Like what?
What should we upgrade?
What do we upgrade?
Look at all these guys.
Wow!
We got a huge army baby!
We are not broke.
We are working on it.
He's got... Uh oh.
Oh my god!
Took him down.
Easy peasy style.
I want to see his little body decay into the sand.
There he goes.
Turn into a skeleton.
Return to the earth.
There he goes.
Should I build a... What's it called?
A place of worship?
So we can have a Wololo man?
I know this is just a tutorial.
I shouldn't go so hard on the tutorial.
But it's fun too.
Okay lady.
All by yourself.
You're gonna build a monastery.
Kill him!
Oh my god.
He really was trying.
He's ghost powered.
Oh yeah.
I'm gonna build a monastery.
All by yourself.
You'll build it.
I believe in you lady.
Okay.
Do it!
With your own hands!
Okay, they're gonna kill him.
Oh damn.
Holy...
These scouts won't have anything to come back to.
Or rather...
They won't be able to say like...
Why did I make you guys chop down the trees so far away?
I think I'm stupid.
Here lady.
Go chop down this one instead.
We have our builder!
Okay.
We can make more stone maybe.
Or actually...
Do that.
Create the monk!
Mint is attacking the English?
Should I leave?
No...
Construct additional pylons.
Wrong game!
They're really coming to seek us out.
They're trying to get a little peek on us you pervs.
My walls are strong.
And my army is stronger!
I know I should build more army people.
We have a monk!
Oh!
Is it this one?
I wonder how...
That's not very...
Priestly of you.
Monk?
Or monkly of you.
Sorry, I know you guys like spam...
Not spam.
Like show like...
You guys are like...
You type in...
11!
Where do I even type those?
I'm not a hotkey type of person.
I'm not very good at remembering those.
So I apologize.
Press enter.
Hi chat.
Wait.
Press enter then 11.
What happened?
I like the sound.
The only RTS game I've played is Lego Battles for the TS.
Try 22.
Is there something that's supposed to happen?
With multiplayer only.
I like to do multiplayer with like...
You know, play this with some people.
Someday.
I think it'd be fun.
We're almost out of gold on this side.
But luckily we have another place over here.
With more gold.
What just happened?
Oh, I created a thing.
What the?
Oh my god!
They're trying to get our walls!
Wait.
I'm gonna go...
This guy.
I think I killed him instead.
He's healing them!
Good job.
Oh, I did convert him.
Okay, now you'll get healed.
Or not.
Heal?
Where are you?
He's working.
Okay, we built our castle.
We're building our army.
Upgrade.
I'm checking on making sure we have enough gold and everything, you know.
Do more damage to buildings?
Sounds good to take down a castle.
Get converted!
Let's create light cavalry.
Which are stronger.
I like stronger.
Hello.
Let's create a knight.
Everybody is chopping down.
We're deforestating the whole world.
We'll get our...
Actually, we have quite a bit of food, so this is easy to research.
We'll research everything that doesn't require gold.
Yeah!
We're winning the tutorial?
We're winning the tutorial!
It didn't sound like...
It didn't sound like a wololo, though.
I didn't hear him say it, though.
Was he supposed to say a wololo?
Wololo.
This counts as beating the game.
Oh, my ships are still gathering food.
Very good, very good.
Let's get more...
This one.
A galley.
And then upgrade to a war galley!
Wait, I think I'm gonna get more people.
Wait, we're all...
Nevermind, hold on.
That's a bush.
Because...
You guys think this is enough?
You think this is enough people to fight?
Yes?
Bring them over here.
We'll gather all our team together.
Gosh, these guys are slow.
Oh, we have these guys too?
Holy moly.
Maybe...
Everybody gather on this side.
He's healing!
Do your thing, monk.
Yeah,
kill that guy.
Alright, everybody come over here.
That's...
That is our meet-up point.
I also don't...
60!
I don't quite understand also...
The formations.
But we'll get there.
Nobody is left behind!
Yeah, we missed a ram.
We got him.
Nobody is left behind.
We're going off to war!
Fear not, peasants!
We will be back with many riches!
Riches!
Now I want a Wololo alert.
Crossbowman!
He got left behind!
Going the long way.
Yeah, but we got to go with our ships.
We got to go with the ships.
It's more epic this way too, right?
Everybody can fit through the gate now, right?
Maybe I should bring another Wololo.
Units are 15% harder.
My guys are not weak.
My guys would not get converted.
Uh-oh.
Oh, we have Stormtrooper in.
Fire this guy.
What the hell?
Oh my god, he missed every single shot!
Wololo is combat.
I watched...
again the other night.
Just because I felt like it.
I watched Top Gun Maverick.
And I was just like, oh yeah.
Top Gun DLC is combat.
I was like looking up the guns and everything.
Oh, let's kill that guy.
Nevermind.
Oh no, they are going to see our army!
Kill him!
Take him down!
He cannot report back!
Oh my god.
Take him down!
They can't know that we are getting ready to attack.
Alright.
Alright team!
Let's go!
Oh wait, hold on.
I can't highlight all of you at once.
Ok, hold on.
You guys...
Alright.
We are going to go take down a whole empire.
A range of empires.
Right?
Alright everybody.
Oh, who did I miss?
I can't get the boats and the guys at the same time.
This is so sad.
Boats...
I think I...
Oh I can only do 60 max.
Ok.
Let's go!
Forward march!
Hold on.
Let's get our other guys too.
Going in.
Alright!
Onward!
Music...
Oh my god!
Sorry buddy.
You are...
So dead.
They were trying to steal our stone!
This is our stone!
150 gifted.
Thank you!
This is our stone!
Rock and stone!
Oh gosh.
How many monkeys does it take to kill one little guy?
Alright, come on!
Keep going!
I'm confusing them a little bit but that's ok.
There they are!
Right across the way.
Keep going!
They all have to like regroup.
They all have to regroup and stuff.
Here we go!
Kill them!
War!
War is upon us!
Can I have the bow?
Take out the...
Yeah, yeah.
Start taking out the...
I don't think that worked.
You start taking this out.
Take out the gate!
Take it down!
Oh my god.
I'm scared you guys.
They seem pretty well off.
They seem pretty advanced I'm just gonna say.
Oh gosh!
Are half of my guys even doing anything or...
Oh my god!
They got in!
Oh my god.
They got in.
Don't die!
I think you can just...
Take it down!
What are you doing?
Forward!
To victory!
I'm gonna miss my bolts.
It's so loud.
Attack!
Alright, let's go start attacking...
Where is their castle?
It's probably really puny and ugly, right?
It's probably really stupid.
No, no, no.
Come this way.
This way.
It's probably so stupid.
Okay, everybody in!
In!
Oh, where is their castle?
Just attack anything I suppose.
No, what are you doing?
Come on!
Get inside!
Inside!
Platoons by holding CTRL 1 through 9.
Okay, I'll have to try that.
We're just attacking anything at this point.
We have no sense of...
No sense of...
Anything right now.
No, no, no...
Oh, there it is!
There it is.
Yeah, keep attacking that thing.
You got this.
Everybody in!
Everybody to the castle!
Everybody... Oh no!
Oh no!
Don't just attack houses!
Everybody attack the castle!
Oh gosh, they're really shooting at us though.
I'm scared.
Did I miss any men?
Yeah.
Come on men!
Hello Raiders!
We are overthrowing the English today!
The Boston Tea Party is now!
Thank you for the gift!
Thank you guys.
Sorry, I was a little stressed trying to get in here.
And the victory is ours!
It crumbled!
The English castle at Falkirk is no more.
The English pretensions in Scotland are surely at an end.
The forces of Wallace are triumphant.
Yippee!
Complete the William Wallace campaign.
Thanks William Wallace!
It did.
Yeah!
We were victorious.
The English castle was torn down and a Scottish one shall be built in its place.
William Wallace has shown us the path to victory.
Although he is but one man, he inspires great deeds in others.
Many of the Scottish knights and lords have drawn their swords with his.
Wallace's own sword is a five and a half foot beast.
Five and a half?
Does he think he is some sort of anime protagonist?
What is it?
He has sworn not to rest until his sword finds the neck of Edward Longshanks.
Oh we are going to kill that guy.
The struggle will continue, but we have learned the ways of war.
Yeah, kind of.
Now it is the English who will prove you wrong.
Wallace Strife.
No!
They beat us in society!
Oh wait, it's a tie.
William Wallace, you need to really pull up, ok buddy?
They beat us in technology!
No!
We are the MVP though.
Yippee!
They lived in a society.
Ah, truly.
That was so good!
I saw... ok.
Someone tried to explain to me how to select...
Hello?
Oh.
Wait, why am I here?
Did I accidentally click back to map?
You can still hear it on fire.
Ok, how do I get home?
To the main menu.
Quit current game.
Ok, return to campaigns.
That's why.
Ok, yay!
General Minky of the Scots truly brought an age of empires.
Is that the thing?
Well now, we have all of our campaigns.
Wait, these are European campaigns.
African campaigns.
America campaigns.
Asian campaigns.
That's a turtle!
Europe.
Western Europe.
Eastern Europe.
South Asia.
Caucasus.
I don't have these ones.
Turtle battle.
Maybe I will stick with the... I don't know.
I have no idea.
Hold on.
Let me see this real quick.
I hate YouTube.
Oh my god.
It won't let me just...
It won't let me click on a thing super chat.
I wanted to read it.
I was in the midst of war.
I can't click it.
I think I got it.
Oh, it was the wrong one.
Anyway, thank you for all the super chats, you guys.
I appreciate it so much.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay.
I like having Joan of Arc, I think.
But I feel like I remember doing that one as a kid.
I want to try something.
I mean, I don't know what I haven't done because I...
Dracula!
Vlad Dracula!
But will they be enough to parry the Turkish onslaught?
In this campaign, you may play as the Turks.
The Magyars.
Sorry guys, I don't know how to read.
And the Slavs.
Wallachia.
Thank you.
Shall we play Dracula?
The Forgotten Campaign.
1448-1477.
Play as the Turkeys.
Heck yeah!
Let's do it!
The dragon spreads his wings!
We have the Ottoman Empire.
Hungary.
Wallachia.
You should play Red Alert sometime if you enjoy, especially Red Alert 3.
Oh yeah, someone was mentioning that earlier.
Moss.
Dragon!
Oh my God we got wolves!
Oh we are just going to take it.
Hell yeah!
Sniper Wolf!
Oh my God!
Stand down fellows.
Wallachia.
He calmed them and satiated their hunger.
Then he turned to us.
Welcome to Pojenary Castle.
Ancient stronghold of the Drachulesti.
Wow!
Cool!
Vlad Dracula must survive.
That's our only objective.
Is that him?
Okay.
Oh I see them on the minimap.
I visited the real castle of Vlad Dracula.
I want to go.
Are you my friend?
And you're my friend.
Wow, nice place.
Okay, spoilers.
Their horses are so cool.
They got like the little wings on them and everything.
Alright.
Men at arms!
Men at legs!
Men at feet and hands and fingers and toes.
Bodies.
Thorax.
Shoulders.
Necks.
We gather together.
And we form one man.
And we will fight!
Oh, that's not our friend.
That is foe.
That must be foe.
We'll go this way.
Ignore us.
Ignore our giant army.
Oh god, they're fast.
We're right outside the gates!
Oh, I have a mama.
Alright everybody, let's keep going.
Everybody survived.
We're good.
We're strong.
My Romanian genes make me proud when I see my Oshi try and pronounce Romanian words.
I want to learn.
Hello friends.
Don't attack.
We come in peace.
Even though we're...
I kind of...
I kind of also want to do not just a campaign, you know?
Kill that guy.
That doesn't sound very good.
Let's keep getting more army.
Not a custom game, but like a random map.
I think we gotta kill this guy.
Where's our monk?
Convert the horse!
Maybe... We converted something maybe.
I'm not quite sure.
Oh my god, they keep coming.
Oh my god, they don't stop coming and they don't stop coming.
Oh wait...
Oh my god!
Vladislav!
It's an ambush!
Where's Vlad Dracula?
There he is.
He's still alive.
He's still healthy.
Can you convert some guys?
Convert him.
Convert!
Ok, you're dead.
Nevermind.
Convert you!
You're dead.
Are your guys gonna do anything or like...
We've lost many men.
Thank you!
Oh, we got all of them now.
Let's go.
He's healing us.
Let's keep going.
Onward.
But yeah, I kinda wanna do one of those like you build your civilization from the ground up kind of maps.
Maybe after this campaign.
After we get the armies and stuff.
Yeah, I wanna do one of those.
Not like story mode, you know.
He said he will follow you but didn't follow him.
I know!
What the heck, man!
Uh oh.
Those are not friends.
Convert!
And you're dead.
Just kidding.
Everybody get healed.
Even yourself, monk.
Vlad is really good at converting Ottomans into corn dogs.
What does that mean?
What does that...
Is that dog trying to...
Oh my God!
The dog is attacking us!
Anyway, sorry dog.
I didn't notice.
Hello!
Don't look up what that means.
I saw them.
Like there is a crazy amount of them over there.
Okay!
I'm taking it.
We want to fire it.
The explosion would surely be enough to demolish that bridge.
Okay!
Take it down.
Everybody else?
Let's go!
We have to take it out from far away I feel.
We can't be on the bridge or else we will die with the explosion, right?
Attack!
Oh there is more guys over here!
Hidden men!
Attack!
Guys be careful over here.
Guys be careful.
Don't get on the bridge.
Get off the bridge!
Nevermind.
Dracula.
Thanks!
I hear wolves.
Oh!
Who are you?
Just some guy all the way up there.
Alright.
Our army is growing.
And also shrinking a little bit sometimes.
Where is our monk?
Is he still alive?
Monk?
Are you in there?
Is he dead?
Oh no.
Did he die?
How?
Oh wait.
He is right here.
Guys.
False alarm.
Click... Who needs healing?
Can you heal yourself?
He is just chilling.
Alright everybody!
Autobots!
Roll out!
More everybody!
I...
I... I feel I... How do I get my guys to all move as a group?
Here we go.
We will just have the others lag behind a little bit.
Okay.
Taking the shortcut.
Nice.
Control groups, but that's hotkeys.
Control 1 to create group 1.
So like, let's say I do this.
Control 1.
Wait, how can I make it?
Okay.
Control...
So group 1.
Wait.
What did I just press?
Change the selected to the next number.
Oh, I didn't mean to do that.
That's okay.
This is group 1.
See?
Easy.
Okay.
Going this way now.
So...
How do I make them all move though?
Do I just like click on them?
And then make them move?
The catapult has friendly fire?
No way.
Now you can press 1 and 2 to select them.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
What's this?
Oh, that's where we started.
They are going to ambush us.
Which group am I pressed?
There we go.
Oh!
Kill them!
Look at these guys.
Good job monk.
Keep going.
Our last ally.
You as well.
Come on team.
We are the best to ever do it.
lol Keep going?
All the way in?
You gotta step inside.
Oh, thank you so much for teaching me about the groups you guys.
This helps so much.
I can just go 1, 2, 1, 2.
Hello, it is I.
Dracula.
If you double click on a unit, it selects all units of that type.
Wait, like if...
No!
Look how he is just casually...
Handsomely?
Well, ok.
Here is the issue.
Now we have more guys.
So, if I do like this...
And I press... What was it?
Ctrl 1?
Vlad is in his own thing.
Wait, no, no, no.
Then, Ctrl 2.
I'm not quite sure.
We are doing our best.
Ok, now I can do this.
Ctrl 1.
Alright everybody.
Ctrl 2.
Attack!
Ctrl 1.
Now that you know how to make groups, you can separate them by type and that's the cornerstone of more advanced tactics and gameplay.
Ok everybody, keep killing!
Murder!
We are gonna go attack this tower.
These guys aren't quite sure what...
They don't know how to cross the bridge everybody.
They are a little... They don't know what to do.
Oh no!
No wait!
You guys are all gonna die!
You guys are gonna die, please.
Vlad is...
They are a little stupid.
Kill this thing too.
It's hurting us good.
It's trying to run away.
You little weasel.
Thank you for the gold.
And the men.
I cannot... Wait, what did it say?
The bridge has been repaired.
Ok, cool.
We can't use anything on these places.
Alright.
Time to make more new groups.
Time to regroup!
Maybe like that?
And then... this?
Ok.
Roll out!
Do it.
Oh wait, I think we left some.
I see them on the mini-map.
Wait a second, there is even more here.
Unless it's talking about these.
Oh yeah, it's these.
Little red ones.
Ok.
But...
I think...
This guy is definitely ours.
You can use the buildings.
So these buildings...
They don't really do much.
They are just guard towers.
Oh!
I can build this stuff!
Fast anti-cavalry unit.
Fast cavalry for scouting and raiding.
Hmm...
We do have food and gold.
Let's just build both of them.
Camels OP.
Oh, not enough gold.
Are they slow to...
We are all waiting for you guys.
Come on!
Hopefully they don't get ambushed.
There is a dog.
I like the sounds a lot.
Let's make these guys...
Everybody come over to here.
There we go.
So as soon as they are created, they'll...
Yeah, see?
They'll start going over there, you know?
As soon as they are created, they'll march over.
Good, good, good!
1v1 that dog.
Not gonna lie.
Uh-oh, I'm getting attacked.
Just kidding.
Wait, you are attacked by player 3.
Where?
Oh my gosh!
Where did these guys come from?
Oh wait, these are the guys that were hiding in the trees waiting to ambush us.
Stupid.
Good job team.
Player 3, that rascal.
He thinks he is part of the team.
Actually, wait.
No, yeah, because it's the light blue guys we are going after.
Blue guys are just like...
We are coming in too.
Look, they are even here also.
Little rascals.
We can create more of these, so why not?
We'll create one more.
Yes, yes, heal him.
Heal him.
Good my monk, good!
My monk heals so well.
I've never played Age of Empires, but I played a lot of Rise of Nations growing up.
Is it similar?
Well guys, is it similar?
Hey, come here.
You're gonna go fight that.
You go fight him.
Oh damn.
Stormtrooper aid.
He won't be one the dog!
Alright, we just have one guy coming in.
Then it's time for war.
D-Dog is dead.
That's not D-Dog.
The music is so chill.
Let's make this group one.
And forward.
Okay.
We'll separate them a little bit.
And...
Group two.
Okay.
Oh, we're getting ambushed again.
You stinking guys, man.
My monk is dying.
Do you ever play Age of Mythology?
I don't...
I think I had it, but I don't remember playing it very much.
I don't remember playing it very much.
I wish if I killed stuff, I could get food.
I'm just taking a pathway.
Hopefully I'm going the right way.
Oh wait, this is the edge of the map.
Everybody reroute!
I didn't realize this is the edge of the map.
Reroute!
Oops!
Come on!
I feel like I did play it though.
Uh-oh.
Oh god, watch out for friendly fire!
Kill that dog.
Kill the dog.
Okay.
The earth is flat.
The map is... No, it's...
Just got invisible walls.
Keep going, keep going.
These dang blue guys though.
Oh my gosh, we're so close.
Everybody...
We're so close to...
To battle.
Secret!
Hidden guys!
Oh my gosh.
How?
Why?
Why are you out here?
They say we belong to no man, no group.
Attack!
Actually, attack, attack.
And you guys attack.
And you guys also attack.
Friendly forest spirits.
I don't know about that.
What am I...
Oh, we're destroying the camp.
Okay.
Attack?
Like get in there?
Start beating stuff up?
Destroy!
It's definitely killing our own soldiers.
We'll have him destroy this thing instead.
You know...
Destroy!
You want him alive!
Huh?
Uh-oh.
I don't think I have enough guys.
Oh, okay.
Yes!
I did it.
I am victorious.
I won a game.
Playing as the Turks.
The campaigns are fun.
I never did them.
I only did the create your own area.
Okay, look at Castlevania.
No peace?
Not on my watch.
Oh yeah.
We're the winners.
Oh, Hungary.
Oh, no society.
We had no society either.
We had one economy.
Can I have one economy please?
One single economy.
We did not live in a society.
Zero society.
Only the Wallachian.
Is that how you said it again?
I don't remember.
Okay.
This was fun.
But like I said, I do kind of want to just do...
Like the single player... It's not the campaigns.
Is it just a skirmish?
Like this is one where we just kind of build our own society and...
It is the skirmish.
Skirmish.
It's a random map.
How many AIs should we have?
Oh.
Whoa.
I kind of want it to all be random though.
It might be fine.
All of them.
Okay.
Wait.
It's only... Oh.
Oh.
Sorry guys.
I'm an idiot.
There we go.
Select your team number.
Players on the same team automatically have their diplomatic stance.
Set to ally and allied victory set.
Okay.
Hold on.
Let's switch this up a little bit.
Let's have like CD...
Oh wait.
HD.
AI.
We'll give it a little bit of a spicy flavor.
Change the map size.
Oh.
It's so tiny.
Let's do Ludacris.
Don't forget to train an ice monkey.
A single ice monkey.
I'm gonna do like 300 population.
I don't know anything.
Allow cheats.
Wait.
Hold on.
Let me get my head out of the way for a second.
Random map.
Sudden death.
Players are eliminated when they have no town centers left.
Oh no.
Scary.
Let's just do a random map.
It could be that one.
Who knows?
Location.
Random.
I'm closing my eyes.
Hold on.
I'll do it again.
Kawasa... Oh.
Kilimanjaro?
How do you turn this off?
What are you talking about?
Wait.
That would be so cool though.
We can climb the mountain.
Hmm.
Can't wait for you to use this cheat.
Who's your daddy?
Wait.
Wrong game.
I don't know that one.
Mountain Ridge.
You know what?
That seems pretty fair, right?
Mountain Ridge maybe?
I don't know.
I don't know anything.
Everything is standard.
Shared exploration.
No, no, no.
Thanks for the super chat!
It's from Warcraft 3.
What's the turbo mode?
No, I don't want everything to be built faster.
Antiquity mode.
Oysters and wood trading.
Record game.
Oh, a record game.
English is so stupid!
It can be record or record.
That's why we defeated the English.
So true!
Regicide.
This will cause players to spawn a king with additional villagers.
If you lose your king, you are... No, no, no.
Let's just do normal.
Okay.
I'm scared.
AI to easy?
No, I think standard is fine.
Right?
If I die...
Put me in the history books.
Say that I was the best who ever did it.
If I die... Is this fine?
Do I need to put teams or do I need to like...
Can I have like two teams on my side?
I kind of want some people.
I want like two people on my side.
You know what I mean?
Oh, sorry.
Like if I put... Okay, here we go.
Players on the same team automatically have diplomatic stance.
A dash indicates no team.
Question mark indicates...
So I could be... Okay, so if I'm like one, that's our team.
And then one is our team.
And then this...
would be random.
They could betray us.
Oh, sorry.
I'm gonna do two for sure and then everyone else...
They could be on our side.
Could not.
We don't know.
EZ and I waits for you to advance ages.
Oh really?
Maybe we should do an EZ.
It's my first game.
Let's do EZ.
18 rabbit.
What?
Team one, team two.
Oh.
Hold on, I'm moving back over a little bit.
What's that?
This is our scout.
Holy cow.
Wait, our friends down here aren't so far it seems.
I think we can get to them.
Oh, there's one more guy.
Turn on auto... Oh, we have gold here!
Big, big, big.
Let's look around the area.
How do I turn on auto scout?
Attack mode.
Defense aggressive.
Patrol.
Click the area.
Lower... Lower what?
The compass, the last symbol.
Oh, this one!
Okay, bye scout!
Turn on auto scout in any game mode.
Oh, we got some... guys here.
Alright, you mister.
You come here.
Yeah, you're gonna start doing that.
We got more gold!
Big, big, big, big.
This game has auto scout.
I love when people learn things when I play game.
Because I learn and then you can learn.
I love that.
So fun.
Okay, we can make one more person.
He'll be our little builder.
He'll be our little builder for now.
I don't learn.
Yeah, I know.
Some of you don't.
Some of you will never learn.
You'll learn!
Look at this.
This guy is the worst scout ever.
Alright, lady.
Start making a little village for us.
Mountain.
Goodbye, scout!
We have stone!
We got stone.
Good, good, good.
Goodness.
What's that?
That's a pig!
Oh, pig's found!
Head on home, pig.
Head on home.
No, no, no, no, no.
Auto scout.
More stone.
Awesome.
Hi.
Little lady, you're gonna build us a barracks.
You know what?
Let's just get into it.
Barracks goes...
Over here.
Nice.
She's backseating the scout.
Where is he?
He's just not optimizing his scouting, you know?
Oh my god!
A relic!
No way!
There's just one right next to us!
Oh my god!
It's just on the ground right there!
How much backseating should we do?
I'll ask for help, you know?
Get it.
We gotta get a monk.
Nice.
Let's get a mining camp like right here.
In the middle of them.
And then we'll get this guy to go over here.
And he'll start doing that... working on that one instead.
A Vietnamese faction.
Can't wait to destroy you.
Stop!
Aren't we friends?
I think.
We're in the dark ages, but we won't be forever.
Let's get some more guys.
Let's get like... two more guys.
Oh, and now she's a gold miner.
No, ma'am!
We need more wood, actually.
So we need you to start...
Start doing that instead.
When is the Paradox or Total War rabbit hole starting?
One day at a time, everybody.
One day at a time.
Look at him go.
Wait, what's this?
There's two of them?
I don't even actually know what these are for.
I just remember doing it in the tutorial.
I don't actually quite know what it's for, even.
I wanna get a lumber camp.
And then we can put it over here.
They give gold over time.
Okay.
You... also do some more wood.
And you... also... wood.
We don't really have much else that I can do, so...
Relics generate infinite gold.
That's huge.
We gotta get it before anybody else finds it.
We need the gold more than anybody else.
Our society is the most important.
Let's go scout.
There he goes.
Yeah, cover that land.
That's not a friend.
Neutral scout.
Who's
that?
Oh, militia.
Yeah, yeah.
We're creating our army.
A little bit.
I wonder if they're close.
Let's see if he's still over there.
I'll just give him a little greeting.
Like, hey, buddy.
How's it going, huh?
Yeah?
You go too.
Yeah, yeah.
Hey, buddy.
How's it going?
How's it hanging?
Okay, we're getting lots of...
We're getting lots of wood now.
Can you build...this?
And you...build...a mill?
Like...
Like here?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm against AI right now.
I wonder if for this game...
Say I wanted to play with you guys.
Is that possible or is it kind of a...you have to...
You have to...
Is it like I can create like a private lobby sort of deal or...
Online play is possible.
It is?
Oh my gosh.
If you guys want to play with me, you guys would probably destroy my kingdom.
You guys would all gang up on me and destroy my kingdom, but...
I think it'd still be fun.
Yeah?
You would play?
I think that guy is long gone.
I was hoping this would be more...
More...ocean.
We can play with Tinas?
Would you guys want to do that?
Oh my gosh.
That would be so fun.
I was just thinking today.
I was like I wish...
That I had a game that I could play with you guys.
That would be so fun.
You could play a co-op game with chat versus AI.
Could we?
Oh my gosh.
Also, if you have Game Pass, this game is free on Game Pass.
But I already had it on Steam, so...
I'm watching this while I research for a paper for my ancient Roman society for culture class.
So, should I also cite this for my paper?
We're not Roman, but...
I think it could work.
Skip ad.
What?
It's not even an ad.
I'm telling you.
If you have it, you can get it for free.
I'm trying to help your wallet.
We live in a Roman society.
Actually, we're Bengalis.
Bengalis?
Actually, I don't know which one it is actually.
Bengali.
Oh!
There's one even closer.
We're gonna have so much money.
Okay, we gotta get a monkey stat.
Bengalis.
Okay.
Bengali is nuts.
Oh my
gosh, yeah.
Eleven would work.
If we had multiplayer, right?
That would be so great.
Everybody's so busy working.
Look at them go.
Look at my little guys.
Let's create... oh wait, I need...
We need someone to build a house.
This is our little neighborhood.
Try it here?
I don't even know what's supposed to happen.
What's going on?
Are you supposed to laugh?
Do all the little characters go like...
Do they do that?
That would be so cute.
I was gonna build some outposts.
Just a few.
Like one over here.
You know, so we can see.
I'm also gonna build some people.
Gonna create life.
It's a setting, maybe.
Hey!
Go do this one.
It's closer, buddy.
We're gonna...
Maybe after the piggies, we have...
We have her build a farm as well.
The outpost has been built.
Let's see.
What do we want?
Actually, let's have you be a farmer.
You're a farmer now.
And you...
What else do we need?
Get out of the dark ages.
We need to go to the feudal age.
We need more food.
Alright, Mr. Farmer.
We need food, food, food.
A tournament.
This one's so scary.
Might be fun though.
Might be fun.
And scary.
I don't think I would feel very confident.
The feudal age.
So true.
We're gonna get money in no time though.
I mean, food.
We'll get it.
Let's just have him finish this tree.
It's almost done.
And this lady is cooking.
I'm gonna create...
A few more, Militia.
O3 food, please.
Is that a command?
Wait, where's our scout?
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
He loves this corner.
He is having the time of his life in this corner.
Try using slash 11 instead.
I did turn that on!
I do remember turning...
Wait, do they all laugh if I go close to home?
Let's slash 30.
Wait, can I make...If I made that a dono sound, would you guys...
I love that.
I get it.
I understand now.
I don't wanna...I wish I had another scout.
Let's create two more people.
Let's max out.
We're getting wood.
We're getting food.
We could get more food.
Try slash 8.
I think I remember that one.
I got you...
Hold on, I gotta take my...I gotta take my cough medicine!
What the hell!
King of the losers!
I hate you!
What?
What does that mean?
I want you to get food.
Question.
Does getting food from animals yield more...
Supply...like more food than getting from like a...
Like a farm?
Or does it not really matter?
And it's faster?
Okay.
So let's build a...
I wonder if I build a mill over here.
Will these guys run away?
The lambs...or the piggies and the lambs just stay for the slaughter.
But...
They won't?
They won't run?
Here, I'm gonna try killing this guy.
Alright.
Alright, we are building our little civilization.
Slowly but surely.
We can...we can go to the feudal age.
You can see all the taunts in the trumpet.
Oh please.
Don't point that...my granny?
Long time, no siege.
Monk!
I need a monk!
What age are you in?
ASL
Oh!
Oh my god, they are answering!
They are in the dark age!
Oh my god, they are answering my question!
My friends!
Guys, there is five relics around us.
As soon as we get a monk, he is going on a great journey.
They are still in the dark age.
It's okay, I'm almost in the feudal age.
I'm almost in the feudal age.
Let's see.
I'm gonna grab...
We are gonna grab someone who will give us...build us another house.
Why did I build a barrack so close to the housing?
Oh my gosh, I'm so bad at this.
I just spent too much money on the plushie and magnets.
Oh no, I'm sorry!
Can't wait for them to arrive and love the streams.
Thank you!
Thank you for ordering them.
I really appreciate it.
Easy AI is pretty chill.
Okay.
I do like just the building aspect of everything too.
I love exploration stuff.
It's one thing that I wish, you know, like with Minecraft...
I love Minecraft, obviously.
I'm in the feudal age!
I love Minecraft, obviously, but I wish there was more, like, stuff with, like, exploration.
I wish there was more way to find, like...
How do you say?
I wish that...
You could...
Have more structures to find and stuff.
I know, obviously, there's mods, but...
You know what I mean?
That's my complaint.
I missed Arteus.
There used to be a lot of them.
Oh yeah!
As soon as monks are ready, they'll be on a spiritual journey.
Yeah.
Yeah, we're gonna be reaping in all the cash money, baby.
It'll be crazy.
In fact, let's get our guys to work more efficiently.
Let's research that.
And research...
This.
And now we can upgrade our men.
It costs a lot of food, but it might be worth.
Yes, you.
Build...
Oh my god!
Attack that guy!
Attack the Eagle Scout!
Hey, can you build a watchtower?
That guy came out of nowhere.
He's so fast.
Holy moly.
Our guys are like, literally not even worried.
Taking their sweet ass time.
OK, give up on him!
Give up on him!
Go back home!
You win today, little scout.
You win today.
OK, we need...
We need more to get the monastery.
Wait, what do I need?
Do I need to get into the castle age?
Oh, this is our friend!
This is our friend, everybody!
Say hi!
Say hi to Scout!
Hello, this is our friend.
Been hosting a Minecraft server for a while.
1.2, 1.4 is a bit of a pain, but a plugin I came across is better structures.
Really?
Yeah, that is exactly what I want.
We need stone, and like, bad.
So let's...
Hold on, there is stone down there, but I thought I saw stone elsewhere.
Maybe not.
Hello Scout, welcome home!
They have advanced to the feudal age!
They are a little slow, but...
OK, let's have a build a... not blacksmith.
I mean, yes, eventually.
Have to build that.
It's kind of sobering to think that this game is older than most of your viewers.
He's back!
Go home.
Go home, Eagle Scout.
I
don't know how to feel about that.
I don't know how to feel about that.
It's only 25 years old.
It can have... Oh my gosh.
This game has babies, probably.
Babies...
That's when, like, people have... Oh my gosh, this game would be married, probably.
It's like when people get married.
This game will...
No.
OK,
we got some stone going on.
We got our stone network.
What do we need for... We need more...
OK, two feudal age buildings.
Oh, actually, that'd be great.
We can get a blacksmith.
We'll get one right here.
And we'll have you build...
a market.
I'm older than the game.
I don't even have a wife.
Well, I said...
I said...
I said mo...
I mean, not all.
You know, don't feel any pressure...
to...
to compare yourself to... I mean, it's Age of Empires, like...
Anybody would marry Age of Empires 2, like...
Don't...
You know...
You're going at your own minto pace.
Slash 8?
What's that one?
No, I'm... It's not...
It's not what you think.
What's Slash 11?
Oh, stop!
I'm new to the game.
I don't remember what the controls are.
I don't remember.
King of the Loser.
Stop.
Stop it.
Oh my gosh.
I don't mean it.
Even if you're King of the Loser, you're our loser, OK?
Right, everyone?
Where's our scout?
Look, he's all the way here.
We found that relic.
What's this?
Oh, enemy territory.
Wait!
Wait, I didn't turn on Share Scouts.
Why am I suddenly seeing everything on the minimap?
Why am I suddenly seeing everything?
It's the Lunar New Year.
Guess what year it is.
It's the year of the snake.
I know!
Happy New Year!
Thanks for the superchat!
Oh, the market does that.
I see, I see.
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
Interesting.
OK.
We're gonna have you be a little farmer.
Yeah, a little farmer lady.
And we have two people who are bored.
What do we need more of?
We need more wood.
Oh, we desperately need more wood.
Hey, why don't you become a lumberjack?
Awesome.
What else can we upgrade?
Alright, once we get to 800 food we'll be able to advance and then we can build a monastery and then we can get gold, gold, gold, gold, gold.
I do have cheats enabled.
I do want to play, since this is like my first real game.
I want to play as much as I can normal.
Before I...
You start using cheats.
So yeah.
13 months of mint, yay!
Thank you!
13 months, oh my gosh.
Thank you, sleep monster, thank you!
What's up, K.R.Z., welcome back, thank you.
Let's go, alright.
700, we're so close.
770.
Do you allow chat to give hints?
What do you consider that backseat?
Why?
What hint do you want to give?
Go ahead, guys, you can give some hints.
Like I said, I've never played this before, so if you want to give hints right now, this is your chance.
This is your chance to give hints.
Okay, let's upgrade.
Don't die.
Right click to attack, okay.
Villagers cost 50 food.
Yep, I can read that part.
No help.
Okay, get stone for walls.
Well, we are getting stone.
This guy...
You know what, he can start becoming a stone man.
I was going to say a stoner, but that's totally different.
Is it worth the extra $10 a month for rising...
Oh gosh.
$10 a month?
Upgrading your lumber camps and mining camps...
You can upgrade these?
Oh my gosh, you can!
I didn't even realize that.
Thank you.
Question, if I upgrade this one, does it also affect...
Does it affect all of them?
Oh, it seems it does.
Maybe?
It says upgrade it, yes.
Alright, I know these are costing us a pretty penny.
But I think they'll be good in the long run, you know.
We're also almost to the castle age.
Nice!
It's research.
That's so fancy.
Double bit... I didn't realize I could upgrade these.
See?
Thank you.
You helped out.
You helped big.
Kiwawa!
I have an AO2 itch.
But it gets so...
It always gets so intimidating by the end game.
It gets so difficult and stressful to me.
Hi Kiwawa!
Kiwawa, would you ever wanna do multiplayer?
With this game?
Do you wanna multiplayer?
Would you wanna build a civilization with me?
And would you wanna take down other civilizations with me?
Would you wanna do that?
Our little army is just chilling.
Oh, we have some guys.
Let's see.
You...
Kill that thing.
Become a lumberjack.
Our first casualty and it's against a pig.
Uh...
That's awkward.
Look at him dissolve into the ground.
I'm sorry little man!
I didn't realize a pig would kill you.
I know the wolves fight.
I did not realize the pigs fought too.
Heavy plow.
Plus one food.
Alright, we're investing.
We need a guy.
We just lost one, so we can build a new guy.
And we can...
We can then...
Build our monastery.
Alright lady.
Hi.
We don't have enough wood.
Okay, keep on chopping.
A university?
Oh my gosh, I never got that far.
Alright.
Wow, this one is so pretty.
Oh my gosh.
Let's build it.
Like right here.
Welcome to Nelo... Sorry, Nelo Wafers.
Welcome... What do you mean not enough wood?
For what?
Thank you.
Alright, once we build this and get our monk and get our relics...
Like there is one right there.
We can stop mining the gold maybe.
I think it will be enough.
Gosh, I need a lot more wood.
My hand feels heavy.
Will you hold it?
Never is enough.
No, keep building.
Hey lady.
Okay monk.
I need you to walk faster.
This one costs money to make you...
Montezuma has advanced to the castle age.
That's not good.
Where is our scout?
Is that him?
Look, they are traveling together.
So cute.
More places are advancing.
But we are the first.
Hey, who are you?
Oh my ally.
Okay, nevermind.
What did you just take?
What are we trading?
Tributes!
Gold accumulates faster.
I like that.
Wait, I can also do this.
Oh, I need more houses.
Does it now trade any buffs or no trading buffs?
Lady, I need you to build a house.
I'm going to have some neighbors.
Alright, go grab that buddy.
Yeah, that's ours.
Tribute.
You steal men's souls and make them your slaves.
Slash 38.
Oh!
Oh my god.
No!
Thank you!
Oh my god.
Wait!
Can I do one for wood?
Oh, come on monk.
Take it back.
Warn me.
Don't just tell... You guys need to tell me what I'm typing in now.
From now on.
What's that sound?
You guys need to tell me what I'm putting in.
I remember what 11 is.
Oh, food please.
Wait, how do I send him food?
Oh shoot, that was in the tutorial.
Hold on.
It was here, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
My ally, I send you food.
There you go.
It will be wisely spent.
See, we're allies so I give him food.
I remember how to do it.
Okay.
8-0-0-8.
That's my favorite command.
And all the women start coming to my place and they're just like...
Guys,
stop.
Stop.
Stop saying type this and that now, okay?
Especially if you're not telling me what it does, okay?
Oh no,
our last stone.
Hey, what else do we need?
It's for food.
I don't need any more food!
Is that our ally?
We have some bored people waiting around.
Oh my gosh.
Hold on.
What was pause again?
How do I get this guy to trade?
Maybe go to here?
F10?
Thank you.
Oh, create a trade route.
Oh, I did it.
I did it.
I didn't even realize.
There we go.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let's see.
Bored lady.
What are you going to do?
What do you want to do, lady?
You can deforest?
You can build?
Let's... I've never built a university.
Oh my gosh, we're going to have smarts.
Oh my gosh, our people are going to be geniuses.
Did he grab it?
Did he bring it home?
Oh, there it... Wait, no, that's her.
Oh, there he is.
Alright, monk.
Your journey continues.
Where is it?
What the hell is down here?
Oh, there it is.
Go get it.
Go get it!
The sounds are kind of ASMR.
It's kind of nice.
If I don't need this here anymore...
Can I like take it down and then build another one over here?
Absolutely ASMR.
Yeah, it's nice.
The university has been built.
Oh, you can just press the delete button.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Let's... Where is the delete button?
Wait a second.
There is no delete button.
Oh, on my keyboard.
Oopsie.
I knew that.
Oh, he got it, he got it, he got it.
Hi.
Back home.
Oh my god, he got it, he got it, he got it.
We are generating gold.
I have so much food.
Hello.
We
are rich.
Can we make a castle?
Oh, we do have a board person.
We can.
I have nothing to spare.
Oh, I don't have any either.
Sorry, buddy.
Castle can go.
We have enemies on this side.
So I'm gonna put it over here, actually.
Put it up on the hill?
Just kidding.
Put it up on the hill, lady.
Oh, good placement.
Wait.
Maybe, like...
Here?
Tactical choice?
Should I just build it where I had it?
I don't know.
Gives you the high ground.
Okay.
Alright, lady.
Oh my gosh, the remnants.
So sad.
You can still use that.
You barely touched your wood.
Oh my gosh, we're really killing it.
Imperial age.
I don't feel like we're ready.
I don't feel like I've aged at all.
We can afford these.
I feel like I'm behind, especially in terms of my army.
I do not want to get attacked right now.
Let's see.
Do I have any...
No, no one who's bored.
Everybody's working.
Everybody's doing their jobs.
Everybody's, you know...
Please make more villagers.
I can make four more.
And then I want to have...
We need, like, the cavalry?
Yeah, we'll need more villagers.
We'll need someone to build houses.
We'll need someone to build places.
Places.
Piggy.
OK.
But we got good supplies, so I feel confident in that at least.
More castles.
We will have...
What?
Why are you saying that?
OK, they're heading out.
No, I'm not going to do that.
No.
I did... Oh, yeah, you can build more town centers.
Yeah, yeah.
I did see that you can build those.
OK, hold on.
Hold on.
Like these, like the siege... Here we go, here we go, here we go.
Here we go, here we go, here we go.
Here, I'll fill...
Maybe you... Oh.
Sorry, I thought...
OK, you build archery.
OK, I'm just ignoring these guys.
Stop!
Get out of my territory.
You guys are going to fall.
You guys are going to fail.
Don't blame me.
Don't blame me!
Stable?
OK.
How much bololo?
Actually, where is our... Oh, there he is.
Alright, monk.
Go get this one now.
Actually, go to get this one.
It seems safer.
He's going to be tested in the very corners of the map.
A.K.A.
the world.
He will see places that he's never witnessed before.
Hi.
Do you want to build a little lumber camp right here?
Yeah.
We'll get rid of this one.
Oh wait, they're using it.
You guys are so stupid.
Wait, you... Wait, go over here.
And you, go over here.
Oh my goodness.
You, go over here.
And you, go over here.
Yeah, we're moving them to another forest.
Okay.
That's our friend.
Where are they?
Oh my god.
Damn.
I'm getting my stuff put together.
Heated shots.
Towers cause 125% more damage to ship.
Well, that doesn't really help us, but...
Yeah, we don't really need that.
We have no water by us.
Those are very efficient lumber camps.
Yes, they are.
Okay, you...
Build...
Elephant Archer!
Oh my god!
You guys, it's time.
Hold on!
It's time.
It's time!
For the elephant army.
Crossbowmen.
You know what?
Just upgrade.
Oh wait.
Oh good.
I do have...
We have some board people.
Build some houses, please.
These guys are like super neighbors.
And you...
Wait.
Hey, you also...
What?
I'm kind of confused what building another town hall will do.
Honestly.
I'm kind of confused about it.
Why don't we build another castle?
Because we are really cool.
You can help.
Adish.
Let's you pump up villages faster.
You can queue commands by pressing shift.
Wait, what do you mean?
Did I get the siege workshop?
No.
We got an elephant!
I'm still making more elephants.
I need to calm down.
Did our monk ever come back?
Oh, he's got it!
How goes the empire?
I think we are winning.
I think.
Never enough elephants.
True!
More elephants.
Needs more elephants.
We got our guys with the stone.
Are they still attacking over there?
Holy moly, they are.
They are really taking them down.
Come on.
And this can also do stuff.
I forgot.
Elephants attack faster.
I don't have so much wood, but we'll still invest.
Send the foreclosure tax.
Yes.
Where did the monk go?
I don't see him anymore.
Oh yeah, baby.
Hello.
Oh there he is!
Oh my gosh, monk with relic.
There he is!
Go to war because others say it's cause.
Is there a way to see how much gold it produces?
Monks can convert enemy buildings.
War monk.
Monks can convert enemy monks!
That's messed up.
Units garrisoned in buildings heal...
I guess if we get attacked...
And we don't want to be converted.
Wololo.
What is Wololo command everybody?
Oh my god.
They are so bloodthirsty.
Yeah.
Wololo.
They are so bloodthirsty.
My god.
And they keep coming through our territory.
I'm building an army.
I'll come to you.
We'll come.
Eventually.
I gotta get my guys up to speed though.
And then, and then, and then...
We go to the imperial age.
Wololo.
Alright, monk.
What other relics do we have?
Wow, there are so many on this side.
Is this normal?
Is this how many there usually are?
Are they
chopping wood?
Why are you chopping wood all the way over here?
Oh, wood please.
Oh, I don't really have that much.
Sorry, friend.
On a ludicrous map, yes.
Wow.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, you're a villager?
Actually, go mine over there.
Elephants.
What else can we build?
Oh, we can make more elephants.
Cool.
Oh my gosh, I have three bored villagers.
What should we make them do?
Okay, I'm just gonna get rid of all my gold.
I need you to mine more gold.
Make them play MGS.
Build more elephants.
Okay, I am...
We're totally getting more elephants?
Check the stable.
Oh, the stable.
This one.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, search cavalry.
Light cavalry.
Upgrade.
Research blood mines.
Yeah, take him down!
Oh god, he's so fast.
And we're so slow.
There they go.
We didn't even get a single shot on this guy.
Oh, you have a relic.
Oh my god.
This guy, are you gonna attack him?
Who are you attacking now?
Who are you attacking?
Oh my god, they're building right next to this.
Are the green guys our friends?
Yeah, they're our friends.
Wait, I could change that at any time though.
I could change that at any time for now, yeah.
Oh my goodness.
Wow, their place is so clean and neat looking.
And mine is...
Guys, I'm not meant for leadership.
Yeah, they're a good shield for...
They're very bloodthirsty though, I'm afraid of...
I'm afraid of them a little bit.
Okay, we need more long swordsmen and some more pikemen.
Bring it home!
You're supposed to attack people.
I know, I'm building my army.
They're just a little slow.
They're just a little slow, you know?
Let's get some crossbows.
Oh, some more elephants.
Reminds me of how I played when I was a kid.
Wait a minute.
We're doing okay.
Right, guys?
We're doing alright.
It's fine.
We're building our army.
It's gotta be big and powerful.
Alright, we have some two bored people.
Alright, let's start building walls now, yeah?
Let's start building some walls.
Actually, I don't know how I wanna build the walls.
I don't know how I wanna build them.
I'm not sure.
You're missing ballistics from the university.
Oh, is that a thing?
Hit fire more accurately at moving targets.
That sounds important to invest in.
Wow, there's hotkeys for everything in this game.
Murder holes!
Eliminates the minimum range for all towers.
So they can fire at enemies attacking their bays.
Oh my god!
He's already on the move!
Who's fighting?
Oh my god.
The yellow guys are just like us.
They're so chill.
Oh no!
What happened to you?
Uh oh, they have...
No, you have to fight back!
I'm being attacked by wild animals.
Where?
Oh my god.
Oh, they got him.
Easy.
Then back to mining.
He didn't care at all.
Should I go help him?
Oh no, he's attac... Oh, he converted them.
Oh my god, he converted the guy who was just attacking the building.
Wow.
Why you no attack enemy now?
Should we go attack an enemy?
Let me build walls and then we'll go attack an enemy.
Where's my monk?
Oh, there's the monk.
Wait, who's over there?
I... I... I... Wait.
No wonder thou wert victorious.
Loser?
Don't need walls?
I want walls!
That makes us feel legit if we have walls.
He'll resign.
Oh my god, they literally...
They're off the map.
Wow, they were up here, weren't they?
How sad.
Snoozy lose, I guess.
That's us, actually.
Okay.
We have big army.
Come on, monk.
We're gonna put you to... Okay, we have two people that need to be put to work.
Let's have you build a mining camp right here.
I'm gonna delete this one.
Oh wait, we'll delete it once this one's built.
Yeah, build that.
What was that gif?
What gif?
I didn't see one.
I didn't see it.
She even gave her housing space.
Yeah, because look, you want them to be happy.
Okay.
Should be done in two seconds.
Okay, goodbye.
Alright, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was spooky?
Was it a streamlabs thing?
Oh my god.
Okay!
I'm gonna attack!
I'm gonna attack.
I'll attack.
Hold on.
Hold on!
We're attacking!
Oh, I built two crossbow things, I just realized.
Armored elephant!
Okay, as soon as our army is done, we move.
As soon as their...
He's out here like, Adish?
Adish?
More elephants, please.
Oh my gosh, we're out of wood!
Uh...
Hold on, no, no, oh wait.
You...oh, there's no more.
Build it right here.
Finally, ally support.
I will, I will, I will.
You need more houses.
Oh shoot.
I need more houses.
Yeah, hey!
Can you like, build a neighborhood right here?
Can you like, I want it to look pretty.
Oh look, look, look.
See, for everyone who's saying...
Yeah, you come build this.
The housing market.
We need more.
We need to build more houses!
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Build that house, build that house.
Hammer that wood, hammer that wood.
Hit that stone, hit that stone.
Never thought I'd hear my Oshi speak Bengali.
That's the power of Age of Empires.
Do, do, do...castles also give housing.
Actually, that's a good idea.
More.
Who are we going to go attack?
I guess we'll go attack the orange guys.
They got purple pretty much down.
Everybody ready?
Hi.
Let's go!
What the hell is that sound?
Oh, it shot down someone.
57.
Perfect.
On the road to kill.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going!
I'm going to attack!
I'm going to go kill.
Wait, how many groups are left?
Orange...wait, where is...
We don't know where silver guys are.
So let's go up.
They might be here.
Right?
They might be...
I am player number 7.
Where?
Oh my god.
You son of a bitch.
Where did you come from?
The elephants are lagging the game.
I was just on my way to attack you.
Also, I just noticed our scout is all the way out here.
This is purple.
Where is the...
Am I crazy?
I don't see the grey guys.
I see yellow, I see orange, but I don't see grey on the map.
Okay guys, let's go.
They must be up here, right?
They gotta be like up here.
Somewhere.
North of the orange?
We're coming!
These are the orange guys.
Actually, maybe we...
What's this group?
This is still... This is not orange.
I don't know.
We're coming!
This way!
They'll make it eventually.
Trust.
They just walked past.
The castle will take care of it.
They're on their way.
They're going.
Preparing to attack.
Where is that?
The orange.
I think...
You're a little behind.
Your monks are slowing the army?
No way, it's the monk?
Monk...
No...
If I make him go home...
Oh I have two of them.
Come on monk.
I don't think they got any faster.
Reissue the command?
Really?
Okay.
I am!
Oh I am.
I'm gonna go attack an enemy.
What the hell is that?
What is that?
Yeah, they didn't get much faster.
They didn't get much faster.
Anyway, you guys wanna go get those relics?
Where were they?
The elephants are slow.
Yeah, I think that's the problem.
That's okay though.
They're good.
They had so many relics, way more than me.
Wait, where was I going before?
It was this way.
Let's go get this instead.
Reroute, reroute a little bit.
Yeah.
Those are our friends.
We're on an epic adventure.
They're gonna go get the relics.
What are you doing out here?
I'm lost.
I don't know where to go.
Oh my gosh, Amita!
Thanks for the...
Thanks for the super chat, girl.
I wasn't hiding.
I was waiting for you, baby girl.
What's this?
We can take it down, whatever it is.
We can destroy something.
We destroyed something.
We took it down.
He already resigned.
Yeah, but we still got it.
We still showed our dominance.
I like that.
And now we build more elephants to attack the red team.
Relic pickup.
Good job guys.
Where are you?
Oh my god!
Those guys... He got his own relic.
I hope he didn't see the gold mine that's right here.
We're almost there.
And no one is attacking this building yet.
We'll be the one to attack it.
Oh my god.
Is it time?
Imperial Age?
Yeah, it's time for the Imperial Age.
I am!
Minto conquering like she's conquered our hearts.
Praying for you, oh great Minto.
Hello!
Oh my god.
Anyway...
Destroy!
You guys kill that thing.
You guys destroy this thing.
Destroy everything!
Make sure nothing stands.
Everything must fall!
I did it.
Wait, my betrayal.
No!
Oh no!
They never got their relic.
No!
My Imperial Age!
1v1?
Should we try 1v1?
It's so quiet now.
I don't think I needed three allies.
You know what I mean?
Oh wait, when a game playing as the Bengalis.
Oh, it disappeared.
Hope the Whisperer is prospering.
I love your recent comedic taste in dying electronics.
Ever seen the demon possess singing trout?
Oh yes!
I love those.
I do love dying electronics.
The thumbnail for this stream is perfection.
All hail, king of the losers!
We didn't even get most valuable player.
But look at this!
You guys, we excelled in everything but military.
Look at our score!
We swept!
How did they get most valuable player and not me?
Am I not a valuable player?
Look at the timeline.
Look!
I don't know what this means.
What does this mean?
Koa!
Hello!
I'm Minto!
Thank you!
I love you!
Koa only!
Minto!
Game good!
Thanks for all the gifts!
Very good!
Thank you!
That's all.
I know.
Thank you for the... Thank you!
Thanks, Sherry!
What does spectate with CA?
Minto is good.
Yes.
Capture H.
Tool for watching replays.
Well, we can go to the main menu.
And I think... I think next time we play...
I want to play with you guys.
I want to do like a multiplayer.
I want to host my own game.
And we can make a big empire.
Maybe like a 4v4 or something.
I will excel in everything but military.
No, no, no.
I'll do good.
That will be fun.
How big of a lobby can we do?
Eight.
So yeah, it will be 4v4.
I will make a password.
I can allow...
Wait.
So allow or disallow people from spectating.
That's fancy.
Spectator.
I think it's because it's private.
I guess it doesn't matter if I make it public or private, right?
People will be imperial before you're feudal.
That's okay.
I'm still learning.
It's okay.
I think it would just be fun to play with everybody though.
You know?
1v1 deathmatch.
Scary.
Public means randoms that aren't wisps might join though.
I think though we would probably have enough people wanting to...
Probably enough people joining quick enough that it would fill up, you know?
Can I still join even if I'm stupid?
Yeah!
I'm stupid when it comes to the game too.
You can set a password?
Wait, even on...
No, you can only set a password if it's private.
Oh, just kidding.
Just kidding?
Mint-toe.
Mint-toes.
And now we got a lot... That could work!
That could work.
Are you doing a game now?
No, no, no.
I think I'm done for tonight, but I had fun playing games of Empire.
This is so fun.
I will... I might play off stream too and get maybe a little bit better.
Or a little bit more used to... You know, I only did the tutorial and then Dracula.
So, if I play a little bit more in the single player, I think I might get more used to it.
Yeah!
This is really fun, thank you.
Thank you guys!
Thanks for helping me out.
And next time... Next time we'll play together, okay?
Next time we'll play together.
Yeah, Art of War is a good tutorial.
Was that a campaign?
Art of War.
Advanced techniques?
Oh...
It's really fun to watch.
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Have a good night, have a good day and I'll see you guys next time!
Otsumito!
Itterasshai!
Thank you guys!
See you!
Bye bye!
See ya!